[Music]
before
last year's halloween show i warned you
not to let your children watch
but you did anyway parent-shaming show
uses the wrong title
the episode isn't called the simpsons
halloween special two it's the treehouse
of horror two they changed the title
part way through
feel like i'm live die repeating all
over again holy hollow ground how huge
is that gravestone
i choose to believe it's regular size
because i want mini hippies to be a
thing
long live the mippies somewhere disney's
frozen brains saw this joke and vowed
revenge by buying fox who's laughing now
simpsons
no one walt no one is laughing peanuts
envy also i like the not to the great
pumpkin gang but why is the witch mask
orange instead of green
if you're gonna make a reference at
least reference correctly remember
the presidential primaries are only a
few months away
hey if you don't like it go to russia in
politics you don't go to russia
russia goes to you somewhere in branson
missouri yakov smirnoff is laughing and
crying at this joke simultaneously
setting out a jack-o'-lantern without
its top hat that pumpkin is missing part
of its skull
lisa can't get through this doorway but
it makes me wonder how she got through
the back door if she can't get through
this
there's no way that amount of candy fit
in that severed head i recognize most of
this candycopia but what is this massive
mound of orange flows that homer is
eating and i swear every handful he
takes replenishes itself homer is eating
out of some sort of everlasting cat hair
pile and i am both confused and nauseous
confucius also gather around children
while i tell you the story of how
reasonable humans would toss uncovered
and sticky popcorn balls into children's
filthy pillowcases to mix with the germs
of 100 other kids reaching into candy
bowls all around town the 1980s building
rock solid immune systems one national
holiday at a time
placing half-eaten candy on your dresser
in case you confused it with
sir i marrakesh strongly advise you to
not purchase this then why have it on
the table with other things that are for
sale
you'll be sorry the shop owner manages
to speak clearly without ever closing
his mouth
he's like whatever the opposite of a
ventriloquist is he's a contrilloquist
funny sight gagging all but where was
the impression of the teacup spout
nozzle when homer's shirt was pulled
down
forget it you two as the pants wearer of
this house i get the first wish the
pantry
oh a new pacifier i get that the joke is
that maggie wasted a wish on a new
pacifier but isn't the whole point of
the monkey's paw that the wish will turn
out to haunt you shouldn't that wish
come with some torturous consequence
like a world where vin diesel can play a
babysitter in a movie that makes 200
million dollars
oh wait it did i blame you maggie
simpson
why would the money just appear around
them but maggie's pacifier would be
personally delivered
homer maybe fame and fortune aren't as
bad as they say
if i hear one more thing about the
simpsons i swear i'm going to scream
so the fantastical negative consequence
of wishing for wealth and fame is slight
public annoyance
howsoever will they survive this
treacherous burden
at first they were cute and funny but
now they're just annoying kids
also i know lisa is the one who wished
for world peace but why would she get
the credit
do people know she wished on a monkey's
paw to make this happen
england hasn't been an independent
country since 1707 and was never an
individual part of the u.n
it's called the united kingdom now you
barmy gets
this maniacal laugh goes on for some
time i get it though how on earth would
you have filled your full 23 minutes
without it
also considering how much kodos and kang
drool and the fact that those glass
helmets are sealed how can we even see
their faces
those helmets should be drool filled
glass tombs at this point
people of earth we come to you in the
spirit of hostility
and menace except that you're on earth
now in lisa's wish was for peace on
earth so
technically you're breaking the power of
the paw here you can't break your own
rules
what do you think this is politics also
kang and kotos definitely did a 180
after that last halloween episode where
they were just trying to be nice to the
simpsons now they want to conquer earth
this lends a lot of credence to my
thought that kang and kodos definitely
did want to eat the simpsons but then
chickened out when they were called out
on it
before i was just bored with their
antics and their merchandise now i wish
they were
dead imagine how we feel 30 seasons
later i'll give you a candy necklace
trying to eat a candy necklace seriously
have you ever attempted to eat one of
those things
it's [ __ ] annoying and gross you
catch it from your side of the family
you know homer waits till bart's out at
your shot to say this but earlier we
learned that bart could read thoughts no
matter where you were
so why does homer get away with this and
our country isn't called america anymore
it's
bonerland yeah that sounds about right
i'm a stupid [ __ ] with an ugly face and
a big
butt and my butt smells and i like to
kiss my own butt
this is what happened when mo answered
the phone before he talked about his
love of butts
i was tavern hold on i'll check
so how did bart tell mo everything he
wanted him to say in the two seconds
before he started talking
i'm not nodding it's the air
conditioning
this is possibly the worst design
ballpark in the history of ballparking
look at all that wasted space around the
stadium
also how do these parking lots even work
i assume there are entry exit points in
the corners but there can be one in this
corner because you'd be trapped how does
anyone even get into a space
yet another also i counted the parking
spaces and if everyone parked properly
there are only 84 spots here
84. if you put 84 spectators in that
stadium it's gonna look like you decided
to play baseball during a global
pandemic can you even imagine
behold the greatest breakthrough in
labor relations since the cattle nine
tails
burns robot was an impressive specimen
but eventually people just called the
robot itself burns because they were
lazy then other people argued it was
okay because the robot thought it was
burns's son so it would self-identify as
burns and never has there ever been a
more important debate in the history of
human discourse
hey here's a good job dad oh wait you
have to know how to operate an
ultrasonic lithotripter lisa is the
smart
one in the family so how in the world
did she think that this was a good job
before she knew everything about it and
the only thing this job could have been
was something in the medical field
28 an hour plenty of fresh air and
you get to meet lots of interesting
people what job is that
grave digger gravediggers make on
average anywhere between 23 and 40
000 even on the high end of that scale
you're making a little over 19
an hour which is nowhere near 28 and
these are current salary rates so i'm
assuming it was even less in 1991
homer survives this and without a peep
serving pizza with grape juice
or wine or the purple stuff from the
sunny d commercial
take that
[Music]
because he's wealthy monty burns was
awarded an honorary degree from the
prometheus school of shuffling away from
things
perhaps you're wondering why you have
two heads i'm more wondering why your
stitching and incisions look fresh when
homer's cranial surgery incisions and
stitching are completely gone no that's
right
it's all a dream or
is it it is for continuity sake there's
no way this is anything other than a
dream the surgery would have had to have
happened between 4 am and now and homer
said he needed to go to work in two
hours which means he didn't lose his job
and he wasn't found in an open grave
later so none of the stuff we saw during
homer's dream could have happened so as
this
very well proves i'm a humorless
butthole
that's called the brain freeze you're
gonna hang with us you need to learn to
sip
despite popular belief we love movies
and we love talking about them check out
the syncast podcast where i'm joined by
my fellow cinemasins creators to talk
about movies rankings rants and more
available here on youtube or
search for scenecast wherever you stream
podcast well
this year's episode is even worse more
blood more gore
carnage candy trick-or-treat man
hey aren't you a little old for this yes
yes i am let's wish for x respects that
really work no
bart peace on earth we are the united
states government we don't do that for
the thing
your attention please
[Music]
alive it's alive
it's alive